rotten launched those missiles shortly
after general Soleimani was buried in
his hometown last night Elizabeth Palmer
is in Tehran for us Elizabeth good
morning what do we expect next from Iran
well good morning the clear message
coming from the leadership is that
they're done at least for now
and that the missile strikes were
specific retaliation for Qasem Soleimani
x' death a news agency farce news close
to the Revolutionary Guards is claiming
that 80 US military personnel were
killed and 200 wounded although they
provide no evidence Iran's supreme
leader described the strikes as a slap
in the face of america but now they're
waiting the ball is very firmly in the
USA's court after a meeting of iran's
cabinet this morning I asked iran's
Foreign Minister Javad Zarif about
moving to reduce the tension what would
it take to get de-escalation going it is
up to the United States
to now come to its senses and stop its
adventurism in this region inevitably
some hardliners led large crowds in
chants of death to America as Soleimani
was finally laid to rest this morning
but Iranians that I've spoken to are
very worried you know they they've been
suffering badly from sanctions and they
really dread a war one thing we're
really seeing clearly today is the
Iranians larger strategic play they
would love to have US forces out of Iraq
so they can expand their influence
across the region and they do believe
this is the moment they may actually
achieve that Anthony Elizabeth Palmer in
Iran thank you Liz